some people assume that you can't really
say what a good or indeed a bad parent
actually is but we don't agree so we've
designed a checklist of what we think
makes up a good parent
firstly and most obvious a good parent
adores their child they're simply
Overjoyed that they exist and don't mind
telling The Offspring that fact indirect
and indirect ways at small and large
moments pretty much every day there is
no risk of spoiling anyone like this
spoiled people are those who were denied
love not those who were regularly bathed
in its calming Waters
secondly the good parent is attuned to
their child they listen very closely
indeed to what the small person is
trying to say
this means getting down on their knees
and calmly paying attention to certain
messages that may sometimes sound
extremely weird or frustrating
maybe the child is saying that they are
very sad even though it's their birthday
and the parent has gone to enormous
trouble with the presence maybe they are
saying that they are angry with the
teacher even if education is in
principle very important and the school
was difficult to get into children are
filled with complicated emotions a good
parent allows these room
a good parent isn't envious of their
children they are strong enough to allow
them to have a better life than they did
good parents are on top of their issues
they don't think it's a good idea to
make someone very unhappy because maybe
someone else made them miserable long
ago
good parents know about boundaries the
game was hilarious for a long time but
now it's the moment to wind down to put
the paints away to get back to work or
to go up to bed the good parent doesn't
mind being hated for a time in the name
of honoring reality
good parents don't mind seeming a bit
boring and predictable small kids don't
need excitement and drama from their
parents they want a secure base from
which to explore the world
now we might think back to our pasts and
give our carers a score out of 10 to
measure how things went it isn't unfair
or mean sometimes in the privacy of our
own minds to hold people to account pick
up a pen and paper as we run through a
list and score each option out of 10.
my parent
made me feel deeply loved and wanted
was often highly attuned to what I
actually felt
was able to tolerate a degree of
innocent disobedience
was authentically happy about my success
lacked sadistic impulses
avoided imposing too many of their own
issues on me
didn't demand to be admired
wasn't too exciting
knew how to play
had boundaries
tolerated descent
took an interest in my small Joys and
pains
we don't need a score of 120 to be
robust but if things were to drop much
below 60 there might be grounds for a
good deal of reflection and sorrow
the best thing if you haven't had a
great childhood is to be as
knowledgeable as possible about what
went wrong and why
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed the concept of emotional
inheritance the formation of our
concepts of being good or bad and the
impact of Parental styles of Love on the
way we choose adult partners